und auch ein ganz großes Thema heute
hier in dieser Sendung über das wir viel
diskutieren und viel reden werden eine
schwule lesbische Kita ja tatsächlich
noch wird einem schlichten Betonbau in
Berlin Schöneberg gehämmert und
geschraubt doch das was da dann entsteht
hier sehen wir die Pläne sorgt schon vor
der Eröffnung für ordentlich Sprengstoff
in Berlin eröffnet die deutschlandweit
erste schwul lesbische Kita ja und er
ist einer der Initiatoren dort diese
Personalie die Macht nur noch
fassungslos im Vorstand des
Gesellschafters dieser schwulen Beratung
sitzt Pädophilie Verfechter Rüdiger
Lautmann das ist dieser Mann und immer
wieder hat er Pädophilie tatsächlich
öffentlich für wortet 1994 hatte das
Buch geschrieben die Lust am Kind
Portrait des Pädophilen und dieser Mann
steckt jetzt also hinter dieser
unglaublichen Kita Gründung
eine schwul lesbische Kita die
deutschlandweit erste sie soll hier im
Frühjahr nächsten Jahres eröffnen ein
umstrittenes Projekt das Geschäftsführer
marcelte Groth und Abteilungsleiter Jörg
Duden von der schwulenberatung Berlin so
erklärt was man hier sehen kann oder was
hier Kindern auch sichtbar gemacht wird
ist dass das Leben eben jenseits von der
normalen in Anführungsstrichen Familie
mit Mami und Papi vielfältig und divers
sein kann also das Lebens- und
Lebensformen eben auch anders aussehen
können und das ist was hier sichtbar
werden
das Konzept in der Kita soll vorgelebt
werden wie es ist schwul oder lesbisch
zu sein dazu soll auch entsprechendes
Lehrmaterial gehören es gibt so normale
Kinderbücher vielleicht die man kennt
aber auch Kinderbücher wo dann der Prinz
ein Prinz heiratet oder die Prinzessin
ein Prinzessin oder eine Prinzessin
feststellt sie ist vielleicht doch
lieber ein Prinz und keine Prinzessin
also es soll spielerisch sagt man andere
Lebensweise
Partei mitgeteilt werden den kleinen
solle es so leichter fallen sich später
zu outen wir haben jetzt schon Bewerbung
gefunden vom Eltern die sagen ja mein
Sohn trägt gerne Kleider zum Geburtstag
ob die Eltern das Feststellen können
genau würde sagen das ist vielleicht zu
früh aber die Eltern wollen auf jeden
Fall nicht dass sie Kind abgelehnt wird
die wollen dass Sie Kind
selbstverständliche Teil der
Gesellschaft ist auch wenn das Kind
nachher schwul oder lesbisch ist also
mehr oder weniger ein vorbeugende
Maßnahme ist für mobil insgesamt 93
Kinder sollen am Südkreuz in Berlin
betreut werden 60 Voranmeldungen gibt
bereits wie es heißt müssen die Jungen
und Mädchen im Alter von erst unter 5
Jahren noch nicht wissen ob sie schwul
oder lesbisch sind alle Kinder würden
aufgenommen und auch eine Kita-Leitung
und Stellvertreter sind bereits gefunden
die Besonderheit ist dass es eben unter
dem Dach der schwulenberatung
stattfindet und deswegen eben das Team
sich vor allem auch zusammensetzt aus
schwulen und lesbischen und
transkolleginnen das ist eigentlich die
größte Besonderheit eine Kita die für
mehr Akzeptanz und Diversität sorgen
soll aber auch die Frage aufwirft
braucht es solch eine Kita wirklich
müssen Kleinkinder wirklich schon mit
ihrer Sexualität konfrontiert werden
Birgit Keller bei uns Publizistin und
auch nicht unbedingt große verfechterung
dieses Plans verfächterin dieses Plans
schön dass Sie bei uns sind wir haben
gerade die letzte Frage in diesem
Beitrag gehört müssen Kinder wirklich in
dem Alter so früh schon mit diesen
Themen sich auseinandersetzen er muss
dazu sagen kitaplatzmangel in Berlin der
ist wirklich groß wahrscheinlich freut
man sich über jeden Kitaplatz den man
bekommt aber ist dieses Konzept wirklich
notwendig
es ist eher notwendig Kinder davor zu
schützen also normalerweise haben wir
Konzepte in Deutschland die Prävention
betreiben dass man Kinder vor der
Sexualität von Erwachsenen schützt dass
wir versuchen es von ihnen entfernt zu
halten in diesem Kontext ist es nahezu
irritierend dass hier jetzt
konzeptionell ein Kindergarten entsteht
der sich ja explizit daran orientiert
Kindern die Sexualität von Erwachsenen
in all ihrer Vielfalt nahebringen zu
wollen und das in einem Alter wo Kinder
überhaupt nicht mit diesem Thema
konfrontiert werden sollten also für
mich ist das eher eine Frage irgendwie
müsste hier nicht allein aus
Kinderschutz Gründen das ganze
verhindert werden
die Regel soll ja in dieser Kita sein
dass man als vier oder fünf Jahre altes
Kind noch nicht wissen muss ob man
schwule oder lesbisch ist sie sind ja
selber Mutter können Sie sich vorstellen
dass eines ihrer Kinder dann in dem
Alter überhaupt darüber nachdenkt und
für sich äußern kann Mama ich bin schwul
oder lesbisch oder eben auch nicht damit
ein Kind von drei Jahren sagen kann dass
es schwul ist müssen sie es ihm vorher
erklären was das bedeutet und das würde
nicht einmal dann verstehen was es
bedeutet weil es nicht einmal
Heterosexualität begreift in diesem
Alter weil das schlicht kein Alter ist
indem man mit Kindern über Sexualität in
dieser Ausführlichkeit sprechen muss
oder sprechen sollte es ist schlicht
eine geistige Überforderung Kinder in
diesem Alter sollten spielen sollten
Bauklötze stapeln sollten mit ihren
Freunden auf dem Spielplatz toben und
sollten nicht überfrachtet werden mit
den Anliegen von Erwachsenen und nicht
stört die Perspektive hier hier wird
immer aus der Perspektive von
Erwachsenen wird ja hier konzipiert das
ist ja nicht Interesse der Kinder dass
sie sich mit dem Thema schwul lesbisch
oder gar Trans auseinandersetzen sollen
in diesem Alter sondern es ist ja hier
die Initiative von Erwachsenen die gerne
möchte dass Kinder sich damit befassen
wir sprechen hier also nicht zu über das
Kindeswohl sondern wir sprechen hier
über Lobbyarbeit die nach Kindern greift
und das ist der wesentliche Unterschied
hier das alles was hier getan wird wird
nicht für die Kinder gemacht nicht im
Interesse der Kinder gemacht sondern im
Interesse von schwul lesbischen
Lobbygruppen und das ist etwas wo ich
sage ja kann man dieses Interesse kann
man haben ich halte es aber für falsch
und ich halte es für Kinder übergriffig
was hier passiert das Argument der
Betreiber der Kita ist ja man wolle so
möglichst früh Toleranz den Kindern
nahebringen und einen tolerantes
Miteinander Leben was setzen sie dem
entgegen
ähm ich glaube das Toleranz nichts mit
Sexualität zu tun hat in diesem Alter
sondern das Toleranz ja auch ein
grundsätzliches pädagogisches Ziel ist
jedem gegenüber jedes Kind ist
unterschiedlich in ganz unterschiedliche
Art und Weise auch erleben Kinder
selbstverständlich auch in dem Alter
schon völlig unterschiedliche
Familienkonstellationen
das ist nichts was jetzt grundsätzlich
sozusagen eine extra Kita Form benötigt
sondern hier geht es explizit um eine
bestimmte und das Thema Sexualität und
das hat das ist nichts was in diesem
Alter irgendwie eine Konfrontation bei
Kindern braucht oder eine extra Schulung
sondern wenn Kinder von vornherein
lernen dass man mit jedem respektvoll
umgeht werden sie das selbstverständlich
später auch mit jedem anderen Menschen
tun egal wodurch er sich von ihnen
selbst unterscheidet das hat ja nichts
grundsätzlich zu tun mit LGBT Themen
sondern sondern lernen Toleranz Respekt
respektvoller Umgang auch mit mit
unterschiedlichen Menschen ist ein
hässliches pädagogisches Ziel dass wir
jetzt allerdings auch schon verfolgen in
den Kindergärten und Schulen also hier
kein Anlass aber weil sie auch gerade
Herrn Lautmann im Bild haben hier ist ja
noch eine andere Komponente mit im Spiel
die das ganze nahezu widerwärtig macht
dass wir hier eine seltsame Verquickung
haben und nämlich vom Thema Pädophilie
und Homosexualität dass wir hier Leute
in einem Vorstand sitzen die kein
Problem damit haben und damit wird das
Ganze bekommt es einen einen nahezu
gefährlichen Beigeschmack denn warum
warum hat man Menschen im Trägerverein
im Vorstand die die gezielt das Thema
Öffnung der kindlichen Sexualität oder
auch den Zugang von Erwachsenen zur
Sexualität von Kindern zu ihrer
Lebensaufgabe gemacht haben
und jetzt will man also mit diesen
Kindern über Sexualität von Erwachsenen
sprechen das ich halte das für
unglaublich gefährlich was hier passiert
hier soll im Endeffekt pidor Sexualität
möglicherweise salonfähig gemacht werden
oder irgendwie be häufig diese Themen
vermischt werden und hier musste
eigentlich müssten die Behörden
einschreiten sagt die Publizistin Birgit
Keller regt sich darüber auf über diese
Form dieser neuen schwul lesbischen Kita
die dort in Berlin Schöneberg entstehen
soll und sagte aus kinderschutzgründen
müsste die verhindert werden danke Ihnen
Frau Keller danke gerne
[Musik]